today the u.s senate is set to debate
abortion rights ahead of that highly
anticipated supreme court ruling the
majority leader says today's vote will
shine like a floodlight to expose where
every senator stands on this very
important issue scott mcfarland reports
from capitol hill
a week of protests vigils and student
walkouts nationwide give way to a
seminal debate today in the u.s senate
why is something that is repeatedly
referred to as settled law
on the threshold of being swept away
like so much dust senate democrats are
fighting for a bill already passed in
the house that would protect abortion
access nationwide they need 60 votes to
pass it but there's no indication
they'll get there this radical
pro-abortion legislation removes a range
of common sense protections that exist
in states
across the country and with the critical
november midterms hanging in the balance
the decision may not be a strong driving
force in elections cbs news polling
found if roe versus wade is overturned
it's likely to have no effect on nearly
half of democrats and three quarters of
republicans there is a spillover into
labor force participation but according
to the nation's first female treasury
secretary it could have a major effect
on women in the workforce and their
ability to boost earning potential
through higher education eliminating the
right of women to make decisions
about when and whether to have children
would have very damaging effects
on the economy and would set women back
decades
the senate is poised to block this
measure by the end of the day and the
supreme court is poised to rule by the
end of next month
tony
got it scott thank you very much